hi this is a science handout from
science mission today we have Andrea
globba from the University of British
Columbia with us she works in the lab of
dr. chadman bumpy and he has won several
awards you know short visit courier or
c1 abandoned and fish Canada about the
Masters and graduate school training
personal development award she also has
won several best for Sarah was as well
as affected I student taught also
welcome mr. Andrea global hi nice right
here yes so thank you thank you for
joining us on science hang out and let's
talk about your background tell us about
your background education etc definitely
i did my undergraduate degree at the
University of Winnipeg in bio psychology
and during my undergraduate training I
had the opportunity to do some research
in some psychology labs and as well in
some developmental biology labs and I
really enjoyed both fields of research
but I found that I was always asking the
question what is happening with at the
cell and protein level that's affecting
behavior and neither a lab neither style
of research really allowed me to answer
those types of questions and that's how
I kind of got interested in pursuing
research in neuroscience and so in 2011
I came to the University of British
Columbia and started working in dr.
Benji's lab looking at the effects of
certain proteins on synapses and
synaptic plasticity and how that affects
learning and memory and I know you are a
busy person with attached students you
develop a lot of powers and off so what
are your other hobby sorry other
temperatures well I I like to stay
active and living
and living in my coover is a great city
to do that because there's mountains and
ocean really nearby so my friends and I
like to go hiking sometimes on the
weekends and in the summer it's nice to
get outside at the beach or go to go
kayaking and i also have been a
competitive softball player for a number
of years and i've recently picked that
up again in vancouver i used to play a
lot in winnipeg and now i'm playing on a
team here and i tell you a distinctive
publication e- admiro signs that is
pretty interesting so can you please
talk and what about 8-10 period of
limitation on the what you have done
sure yeah that's that will be the focus
in my presentation so do I just share
the screen at email yeah sure okay okay
all right so can you guys see it yep
okay good um alright so I'll be I'll be
taking you through the findings of this
paper today but first to give you some
background many researchers think that
the cellular basis for addiction is
synaptic plasticity gone awry in the
dopaminergic circuitry of the brain and
we all know intuitively that the
predisposition for addiction can vary
from person to person and it's thought
that these differences are due to
differences in genetic variation and
certain single nucleotide polymorphisms
in genes have been identified and in
particular one of the families of genes
that's been shown to have mutations in
people that are at risk for addiction is
cell adhesion molecules and these are
really important some of them in synapse
formation and some of them in synaptic
plasticity and so we were interested in
in looking AXA cell adhesion molecules
and determining whether they play any
role in the pathological plasticity
that's been shown to occur in addiction
so to give you some background on the
cell adhesion molecules in the brain as
I mentioned there's several different
types of these salad Heejun molecules
now most textbooks show the pre and post
synaptic cleft hovering in space but
there are actually several families of
cell adhesion proteins that hold these
synaptic sites together and some of
these are important for synapse
formation and we were interested in CAD
Kieran's which are important for
synaptic plasticity in particular now
kadir ins are home affiliate heejun
proteins that are present at both the
pre and postsynaptic membrane of
synapses and they're shown here in green
now Karen's interact both insists and in
trance and form a lattice that holds the
pre and post synaptic terminals together
and these have been shown to play an
important role in synaptic plasticity in
the hippocampus increased television is
necessary for the strengthening of
synapses or long-term potentiation now
after high-frequency stimulation or a
learning event there's increased this
clustering of kid hearings at the
membrane as well as increases in the
amount of both kid hearin and ampa
receptors of the synapse which results
in the increase in size and stability of
dendritic spines so this increased could
hear in adhesion is necessary for
synapse strengthening in fact blocking
adhere and interactions in the
hippocampus can prevent both the
strengthening of synapses and
context-dependent fear conditioning so
we wanted to know if these same
mechanisms of learning were important in
plasticity in another region of the
brain and in another type of behavior in
particular in addiction so we decided to
so before I continue I just wanted to
mention that some of the snips that I
was talking about have been identified
in kid hearing proteins and some of
their binding partners and there's
actually been shown to be increases in
the expression of one of the binding
partners beta-catenin after exposure to
cocaine so there was some back up some
evidence to support these ideas that we
were going to follow up on so we decided
to look at a region of the brain that's
involved in addiction and so as I
mentioned there's evidence from these
jiwa studies that kid hearings are
important in plasticity so first we
looked at the ventral tegmental area or
VTA now the VTA contains a population of
dopamine
cells which project to the nucleus
accumbens and the prefrontal cortex and
importantly all addictive drugs increase
dopamine transmission from the VTA to
other parts of the brain and these
dopamine cells receive glutamatergic
inputs and gabaergic inputs and it's
thought that by changing the strength of
these inputs you might be able to
control the excitability of these
dopamine cells and potentially drive
changes that result in addiction and so
other groups have identified changes at
synapses onto dopamine neurons in
response to cocaine so this is a
excitatory synapse forming on to a
dopamine neuron and at baseline the ampa
receptors at these synapses are glue a
12 HED rumors and these allow sodium
into the cell however after exposure to
cocaine there's this switch that occurs
where glue a 12 HED rumors are removed
from the synapse and glue i went homers
are inserted and this these glue and
homers allow calcium into the cell which
results in this increased potentiation
of the synapse and so I should just
mention we know that coherence can
interact with the ampa receptors and so
this is another reason we thought maybe
cut hearings are important in this type
of plasticity but first we wanted to see
it confirmed that they were actually
expressed in this region of the brain so
we did some immunostaining for a number
of classical coherence and we saw that N
Kiran and several related kid hearings
are all expressed in these dopamine
cells in the VTA and we did some
electrophysiology with our collaborators
at in Stephanie borgland lab at the
University of Calgary and her postdocs
why did a spike time-independent
plasticity experiment and so normally
they do they do this technique a lot in
their lab where they use this by timing
protocol to drive these increases in
epsp amplitude after after the spike
timing protocol and so we determine
whether Kieran's were important in this
type of plasticity so I pretreated some
brain slices with a peptide that blocks
could hear and kick hearing interactions
and we found that when we pretreated the
slices with this peptide we were able to
block this type of plasticity
and to confirm the specificity of the
peptide we also used a scrambled peptide
and showed that we were able to induce
normal increases in synaptic strength so
this showed us that kid hearings were
present in the VTA and were important
for synaptic plasticity in this region
so we next wanted to know if there were
changes in kid here and localization at
VTA synapses after mice developed a
preference for cocaine so to look at
this we used an experiment called
conditioned place preference and so in
conditioned place preference we use a
three chambered box where chambers a and
chambers be are distinct and yet equally
preferable and we watch we're the mice
so we put the mice in the chamber during
habituation day and we see that they
spend about equal time and chambers a
and B we then proceed to a set of
conditioning days where mice received
cocaine in one chamber and saline in the
other and after doing this for several
days in a row the mice learned to
associate the rewarding effects of the
drug with the context in which it was
experienced and we can test their
preference for the cocaine by again
putting them in the chamber and allowing
them to choose where they spend their
time and we see that wild-type mice
spend significantly more time in the
drug para after conditioning so at this
time point we collected brain samples
from the VTA and we did a technique
called immunoelectron microscopy which
I'll tell you more about in a minute and
we also didn't took another cohort in my
son did the exact same experiment but
after test day we kept putting them in
the chamber each day and watching their
preference for the drug para get reduced
over time and so after they'd
extinguished their preference we also
collected samples for immunoelectron
microscopy so this is the behavioral
data from that type of experiment and
you can see that after conditioning the
cocaine treated mice show the
significant increase in their preference
for the drug para whereas saline control
mice which about salient on both sides
spend about the same amount of time in
the chamber throughout the experiment so
we've taken our VTA samples from these
brains and we wanted to identify
excitatory and inhibitory synapses which
performing on to dopamine neurons in the
VTA but this is a very heterogeneous
brain region with dopamine cells lots of
gaba cells and so we really wanted to
nail down the type of synapses we were
looking at so we first wanted to
identify dopamine cells and so to do
that we immunostained for a marker of
dopamine cells specifically the dopamine
transporter dat and we look for that in
postsynaptic compartments and that
allowed us to identify dopamine cells
that were receiving inputs we then also
wanted to identify excitatory and
inhibitory synapses and you can do this
by morphology but we also immunostained
for a marker of excitatory synapses like
psd-95 and then we also looked at jeff
ring for inhibitory synapses and this
allowed us to distinguish between the
excitatory and inhibitory inputs forming
on to these dopamine cells now the final
marker we looked at was forked hiren and
so when we immunostained forked here and
which is the smallest bead size here
with the blue arrows we see this
distribution around synapses and the way
that we quantified this was we measured
the distance of each of these immunogold
beads to the pre or post synaptic
membrane depending on which compartment
they were in and this really gives us a
sense of the distribution of the protein
around the synapse and just to kind of
let you guys know we we looked at the
size of based on the crystal structure
of the size of the protein and the known
sizes of antibodies and the gold beads
we considered any labeling within 40
nanometers to be labeling could hearin
that is likely inserted in the synaptic
membrane and participating in trance and
affricate heejun so when we did this for
the mice they went through our
behavioral task we saw that the cocaine
group showed the significant increase in
the amount of kid here and localized to
the synaptic membrane compared to their
saline controls and this was strongly
correlated with their behavioral data
such that the mice that spent the most
time in the condition chamber had the
greatest amount of kid here and a
synaptic membrane now in contrast when
we looked at inhibitory synapses we
didn't see any changes suggesting that
these changes in could hear and
localization were really specific too
excited
two inputs and so we did a number of
control experiments as I mentioned
before we looked at what happens after
extinction and showed that after so the
mice had developed this preference for
cocaine we show this increase in kid
here and at the membrane but after
they'd extinguished their preference the
amount of concern of the membrane is
back at baseline we also wanted to know
whether the changes we saw were purely
due to the physiological effects of
cocaine or whether this would occur due
to like whether this was due to the
conditioning and that associative
learning that was occurring and when we
looked at a home cage control group of
mice which received cocaine on the same
schedule as our behavioral group but
didn't go in an e novel environment they
just stayed in their home cage each day
we showed that they didn't have an
increase in they could hear and localize
to the membrane which suggested to us
that there really was something about
that associative learning that was
driving these changes and so and to sort
of look at the extinction and as a
control for the extinction experiment we
also took a group of mice where we
conditioned them in the not in the novel
context of the conditioning chamber and
then rather than extinguishing them in
the chamber each day we kept them in
their home cage for six more days to see
whether the effects that we saw at the
extinction time point where due to that
learn unlearning or some would argue is
a new form of learning that the chamber
is no longer preferable or whether this
was a passive effect that would happen
no matter what and what we saw was that
after the homepage extinction is what we
kind of called it when we were doing the
experiment after that six days of just
staying in the home page k hearing
levels were back at baseline as well
which suggested that there needed to be
this transient increase in kick urine
during conditioning but this wasn't
necessary to for extinction this was
going to would be reduced no matter what
and then finally we did a food CPP
experiment so we wanted to know whether
the effects we saw were specific to
addictive drugs or whether any natural
reward would also drive changes and so
although these mice showed a
conditioning effect where where they did
show preference for the bacon-flavored
treats that we conditioned them with
in the one chamber they didn't show an
increase in kid here in localization so
we also looked at glue a1 localization
at synapses and similarly to adhere in
we saw that after conditioning in the
drug peddler there was a significant
increase in glue a one local s to the
membrane which was also strongly
correlated with each mouse's behavior
and so we wanted to know if could hear
an and glue a wine for trafficking
together and one other experiment we did
was we immunostained for glue a one and
could hearin in the same samples and we
showed that synapses that were high in
glue a1 were also high in Kidd youren in
both our saline controls and in our
cocaine CPP mice so this suggested to us
that the kirin and glue a1 were
trafficking together whether we were
looking at saline-treated mice or
cocaine treated mice but the difference
we saw was in the number of synapses
that were fit into each of these
categories so the cocaine group had a
significantly higher number of synapses
that were both high and could hear in
glue a one and have significantly fewer
synapses that were low in both get here
in a glue a one suggesting that more
could hear it and glue a one we're both
trafficking to these synapses so we'd
shown that there are these changes in
kid hearin and glue a1 localization
after mice develop a preference for
cocaine so we next wanted to know if we
stabilize coherent at the membrane could
we have any effect on the drug mediated
learning or the drug based mediated
behavior and so to examine this we took
a transgenic approach where we use a
conditionally stabilized beta-catenin
mousseline and so these mice have a
floxed exon 3 allele an exon 3 contains
some phosphorylation sites where which
when they're phosphorylated normally
mark beta-catenin for degradation by its
normal mechanisms but in these mice we
were able to produce a mutant form of
beta-catenin which could not be
phosphorylated and therefore could not
be broken down and so we used a Cree
line where we were only expressing
korean dopamine cells which meant that
we were increasing beta-catenin
stability specifically in dopamine cells
and so to show the validation of that
you can see that we see significantly
higher levels of beta-catenin
immunostaining in our mutant mice
compared to our wild-type controls and
so by increasing beta-catenin stability
we could increase coherence
stabilization at the synaptic membrane
beta-catenin interacts with Kidd youren
and prevents it from being endocytosed
when it's interacting so by increasing
the amount of beta-catenin in these in
these dopamine cells we were increasing
could hear instability at the membrane
and for any of you cell and
developmental biologists out there who
are listening we did look at wendt
signaling to and confirmed that in our
mice we didn't see any increases in the
expression of wint targets in these
dopamine cells furthermore our lab has
used this mouse line in the past in the
hippocampus and we've shown that there
weren't off target downstream effects on
weight signaling in these mice so just
so let you guys know in anticipation of
a question so when we took these mice
and we we took them through the same
conditioning conditioned place
preference experiment we showed that
they spent significantly less time in
the condition chamber compared to our
wild-type control mice and so this was a
really interesting to us and just remind
you as how the plasticity in this part
of the brain works after exposure to
cocaine or other drugs of abuse ders at
these excitatory inputs on to dopamine
cells undergo this change where normally
their glue a 12 HED Irma's but after
cocaine administration we get the
insertion of more glue and homers at the
synapse and what's interesting is one
paper has shown that it the
internalization of the glue i went to
header murs is necessary for this type
of plasticity and if you block that
internalization you actually block the
insertion of gluon homers and so we
thought that was pretty interesting and
we thought that perhaps kid hearings
were impairing plasticity in this region
of the brain by interfering with this
amp receptor cycling oh oops and so
to test this we went back to her
immunity em and we took em you know em
samples from wild-type and the
beta-catenin mutant mice and we did some
more immunity em and so as we've seen
previously in our wild-type mice after
conditioning they show this increase in
could hear and localized to the synaptic
membrane but in our mutant mice there
was an increase in hearing at baseline
which and then there was no further
increase after conditioning and so this
fit really well with our with our
expectation that these mutants would
have increased could hear instability at
the membrane and it was interesting to
see that there was no further change
after the conditioning we then looked at
glue a to localization and so when our
wild-type mice we saw that after
conditioning there was this significant
decrease in the amount of glue a to
localized to the synaptic membrane which
indicated to us that those glue a went
to head rumors were likely being removed
from the synapse in these wild type mice
but in our mutant mice this was
completely blocked which was indicating
to us that perhaps could hear and was
interfering with this type of plasticity
finally we looked at glue a1
localization and as we've seen
previously in our wild-type mice we show
the significant increase in the amount
of glue a one at the synaptic membrane
after conditioning indicating to us that
glue a one homers were being inserted at
the synaptic membrane but again in our
mutant mice this was completely blocked
suggesting to us that by blocking the
internalization of the glue a went to
head rumors we were likely interfering
with the insertion of glue a one homers
at the synapse so we also examine this
using electrophysiology again with
Stephanie Bourland lab at the University
of Calgary so her postdocs why looked at
a few different measures that are
commonly used to look at the type of
receptors present at these excitatory
synapses onto dopamine cells in the VTA
so first they looked at something called
the ampa to nmda receptor ratio and in
the wild-type mice they saw that after
cocaine condition after a cocaine
injection there was this increase in the
aan ratio which others have shown
indicates that there are more ampars
afters being inserted at these synapses
but in our mutant mice again this was
completely blocked indicating again that
the increased kid hearing was
interfering with plasticity in this
brain region and they also looked at
something called the rectification index
so this gives us an idea of the type of
ampa receptor that's present at these
synapses now glue a 12 HED ermer type AB
receptors as I mentioned are calcium
impermeable and therefore they have a
linear rectification index but the glue
a one homer type ampa receptors are
inwardly rectifying and this results in
an increase in the rectification index
which is shown here and this is what we
saw in our wild-type animals and there's
an increase in linear rectifier it in
inwardly rectifying synapses now in our
mutant animals again this was completely
blocked indicating that the glue a one
homers were not being inserted at these
synapses so together this data shows
that there are impairments in plasticity
in our beta catenin stabilized mice so
to summarize normally after mice are
given cocaine paired with a novel
environment there's a removal of the
glue a 12 HED rumors an insertion of
glue a when homers at these synapses and
this change in amp receptor subtype is
facilitated by CAD here and turnover and
increased could hear instability at the
synaptic membrane which results in the
potentiation of synapses and a strong
preference for cocaine by in our mutant
mice where Karen is already stable at
the synaptic membrane there's the
internalization of glue a 12 header murs
is impaired and some researchers believe
that there's only a certain number of
ampa receptor slots at these synapses so
when the glue a went to header more
internalization is blocked there's no
space for other receptors and the
insertion of these calcium permeable hue
one homers is also blocked so this
results in impairments and synaptic
plasticity and impairments in the
acquisition of conditioned place
preference so that's kind of sums up the
whole paper
we're kind of interested in I believe
we've talked a lot about what the next
step for this project might be and we're
interested in looking at other other
targets that can interfere with or
facilitate kid here in adhesion and and
might play a role in this type of
plasticity and hopefully we could
identify proteins that are more specific
to this circuit in this pathway which
encode hearings are also very important
in learning and and important in
plasticity and other brain regions so
ideally it'd be interesting to discover
some protein that is more specifically
expressed in the midbrain or more
specifically expressed in dopamine cells
that could act on coherence so I just
want to make it take a moment to thank
all the lab members that I worked with
specifically with my co-first author
Fergal Mills who was a huge part of this
project and as well the funding agencies
like cihr which supported myself and the
lab all right that's a good presentation
on Andrea can you please sir yeah yeah
thanks thank you so much it was very
interesting Thanks I have a couple of
questions sure like have you looked at
any protein synthesis of there is no
protein synthesis effect on the like
changing oh we didn't examine that
specifically um we we did look at the
total labeling of kid hirons when we did
the immuno am experiments and we didn't
see any changes in the levels when we
looked at the e/m level but we haven't
examined it by like western blots or
anything like that the VTA of the mice
are very small so we need to pool the
the protein from several mice to do that
type of experiment properly open and
like is there any other like receptors
like ampa receptor cells have that
subtypes right yeah we were looking
mainly at glue a1 and glue a to
I have been asked whether glue a three
is as part of the ampa receptors that we
were looking at we didn't specifically
immunostained for glue a three although
I guess it could definitely be part of
some of those ever scepter subtypes and
if you know that exactly on the Kennedy
man that is a very vacuum that happens
like what is the like when they embody
Kamali well Connecticut has been shown
to interact with both glue a1 and glue a
to post directly and indirectly through
proteins like grip and so it's it's
because I was something we were
wondering about as well in the first
part of the talk I told you about how
kid here ins are important for driving
synaptic plasticity and then I've shown
when you increase could hear and we
impaired plasticity so it's kind of a
bit counterintuitive at first but I
think what's really important is the
timing of when you increase the kick
here in localized to the membrane so in
the wild-type mice could hear it
increases during potentiation when those
glue a one homers are present at the
synapse so I think then it will help
stabilize the gluon homers and drive
that plasticity whereas in our mutant
mice we have increased could hear in at
baseline and so at baseline we have the
glue a 12 header emerged present and
therefore we're stabilizing the the
receptors that are going to be calcium
impermeable and that's that's where
we're seeing the impairments in
plasticity and in behavior okay and have
you used any other drugs like this is
like you have been poking cpp and all
like we just did buy cocaine CPP um
other other groups that have looked at
this type of plasticity have shown that
other drugs such as M feta means and
nicotine and ethanol all drive the same
type of changes at these synapses so I
would imagine we might see similar
effects with other drugs but that's not
something we've looked at directly looks
like it is a common mechanism so you can
but universally you can if you think
that okay but some way of interventions
any other drugs also you could use the
same subdivision
yeah hopefully it's there some
commonality I mean it definitely would
be something to look at it and obviously
all these drugs act slightly differently
but they do seem to drive drive some
similar changes in plasticity so okay so
what do you want to do this current
projects like going forward so are you
look like what's on deck like how did
what is your plan well personally my
plan is to graduate soon so um there
will be a few like a new post doc who's
looking at some of the same things
looking at some other proteins our lab
has previously shown that enzymes like
ehh c5 can act on the key here in
adhesion complex by Paul methylating
Delta catenin which is another binding
protein of kid here and so be
interesting to see if if a DHD five
expression might have effects on this
type of plasticity so that those sort of
avenues like seeing what other
downstream proteins might have an effect
on Kieran adhesion in the VTA I also
think it would be interesting to look at
plasticity and other related brain
regions such as the nucleus accumbens
because we know that this type of
plasticity and the VTA is quite
transient man drives downstream changes
in the nucleus accumbens that would be
interesting to look at that spring
region and see if what type of changes
in coherence or other solid Asian
proteins might occur in there that's an
interesting question in the sense that
addiction is a long-term I mean like
once you get addicted like some changes
has to happen for a longer period of
time okay so certainly there might be
more to them definitely and and there's
we were not trying to say that
conditioning with three doses of cocaine
is equivalent to a lifetime of drug
addiction and those types of other
factors that might be a play for sure
but yeah it's definitely you know it's a
model and you have to start with that
with something that's worth it it's an
interesting finding did you like when I
will click the news about that so I was
getting three yeah you can intervene
some realize I'm like that is one of the
biggest challenges what we have is like
of us
is have some understand more about what
happens in the brain so very possibly
their leader someone you may thank you
so much I really appreciate you taking
time and good luck with your depending
thesis in the summer and for all urs
future research endeavors I really
appreciate your time thanks very much
it's been some time thank